Michael good to see you pretty
dismissive there from Russia about the
tanks that Britain's planning to send to
Ukraine do you think this will influence
any decisions that are being made by
defense ministers in the west no um the
Kremlin can say what they're like the
fact is the Challenger along with the
American Abrams tank and the leopard two
tanks which is what being are being
talked about are infinitely Superior do
anything the Russians have got on the
battlefield the Russians are operating
272s t80s 290s the Challenger is better
than all of them and would take a hit
from them and still not be affected so
it's a very very good tank the issue is
timing is that the meeting in Ramstein
this week on Friday will decide whether
to send you know let's say more than 100
tanks to Ukraine not just the British
14. if it takes 20 weeks to train a tank
crew if that's compressed let's say to
10 or 12 weeks in an emergency and it'll
take 10 or 12 weeks to get the tanks
there so if in 12 weeks time when the
Russians are beginning their offensive
there are significant tank forces there
from the west then everyone will say
that the Ramstein meeting their
decisions were taken just in time but if
they're not taken on Friday it'll be
just too late we're at the last possible
time when a sensible decision can be
made to train the crews get the tanks
there for the spring when they will be
needed and can we talk about this
collaboration between Minsk and Moscow
and the joint training exercises as
they're calling them they're playing
them down but is there significance
behind this what's your take on what's
Happening I think the Russians are
trying to stretch the Ukrainian so
they're trying to give them a give them
something to worry about Up On the
Border but I mean the border with
Belarus is a very big board but it's not
all that useful the belarusians are very
reluctant to get involved even if the
Russians come across the border and the
pripyat marshals the famous pripyat
marshes run right to the west of that
area and those marshes are very very
watery nobody wants to cross them in
February this year when the Russians
invaded they invaded on a very narrow
front much further to the east of the
pripyat marshes and that's what they'd
have to do again because the marshes is
a huge Wetland area and this winter it's
became become even more of a wetland
just because of local climactic
conditions and so on so nobody wants to
drive a tank Army over this sort of
terrain in reality if the Russians not
the belarusians but if the Russians came
again from Belarus they'd still be on a
narrow front the ukrainians would see
them coming and would be able to deal
with it I would imagine given that
they're now so much better prepared than
they were in February so that's
potentially what could happen let's have
a look at what's actually happening
right now particularly in the east of
Ukraine the fighting continuing there
Michael yes it looks if the Russians
have got solidar it looks as if they've
lost about 15 000 of the Wagner group
soldiers five thousand dead another 10
000 wounded and if that's fifteen
thousand out of the 40 odd thousand that
they seem to have so they've paid dearly
for solidar if they got it and they
think they probably have they're
probably now going to move to back but
they're trying to surround back more
from the North and the South there's a
lot of fighting going on to the south of
bakmut the ukrainians might struggle now
to hang on to back mutt but they won't
lose it quickly we'll see about that the
issues are not really solidar and back
mud the Russians are paid so much for
that the Russians are in trouble in
criminal and if they lose criminal
they're in big trouble because
ukrainians will then begin to circle
around behind them and the Russians only
make a make an advance from solidar if
they can get to slavigantic and
chromatos they are still as ever they're
the strategically important parts of the
dumbass and unless the Russians can take
slavians and climate task and the
ukrainians have made them into a
fortress already then they don't get
much further so although I think they've
had a success at solidar they may be
successful at back mud it won't mean
very much if they lose cremena and they
can't move on to slavians and chromatosk